got the situation they got me facing I
can't live a normal life I was raised by
the state so I gotta be done with the
hood team too much television watching
got me chasing dreams all my educated
fool with money on my mind Mack 10 in my
hand in The Gleam in my heart I'm a
locked out gangster said tripping Banger
and my homies is down so don't arise my
anger fool depth ain't nothing but a
Heartbeat Away I'm living life do I die
what can I say I'm 23 now but will I
live to see 20 both away they just go
and I don't know tell me why are we so
blind to see that the ones we hurt are
you and me yeah yeah
yeah been spending most Our Lives
[Music]
[Applause]